[Music]
all right so we wanted to answer the
question once and for all what is the
best smartphone camera out right now
maybe you think it's the iPhone or maybe
it's a Samsung Flagship or maybe it's
one of those pixels now in years past
we've done a blind voting using social
media polls which was really fun and
yielded some surprising results but that
would still depend on the matchups that
I planted at the very beginning so I
specifically put the iPhone and the
pixel on opposite sides of the bracket
expecting the best ones to hopefully
meet in the finals but they never did
and there's always a bit of human input
it's actually possible I could have
accidentally put the second best phone
up against the best phone in the first
round and it got eliminated so this time
we're going to solve all that once and
for all welcome to the blind smartphone
camera test scientific Edition so here's
the idea we took 16 smartphones that
came out during this year the flagships
your expected Heavy Hitters but then
also some mid-rangers as well all the
way down to the unexpected and then we
took the same exact photo with each one
of them harder than a sound because you
have to hold perfectly still for several
minutes straight but we actually did
this for three different types of photos
a standard daylight photo a low light
photo and a portrait mode snap and then
we take all these images compress them
strip them of their exif data and
assigned each one a letter now for
maximum statistical confidence we would
have to ask you guys to vote on every
single possible matchup at least once so
a versus B then a versus C then a versus
D all the way through and then B versus
C B versus D over and over 16 choose two
for my stat heads but that's clearly a
bit too much I mean we want to be
scientific but having you sit there and
vote over a hundred times for each
category was a bit of a tall ask so
instead we got a little clever with it
and we built a power ranking system
actually an ELO rating algorithm which
you might have heard of they use this in
chess they use this in table tennis and
basically in any video game you've
played where there's a bunch of
different match UPS all happening at
once and you need to form a ranking of
them but this time we'll be using it to
sort of form a power ranking of
smartphone cameras so basically when you
hit enough sanctioned matchups you're
given a rating based on the ratings of
your matchups so you along with
everybody else gets shown comparisons at
random and we have this little progress
bar along the bottom you vote for the
better photo each time and then after a
little while we have enough information
to determine your individual customized
statistically significant winner so we
built this whole site with the ELO
rating system in there we loaded up all
the photos and then we actually tossed
this first into our Discord to have some
of you beta test this before anyone else
knew it existed so we could experiment
with the data formatting on the out end
so we could make sure it was all
organized so actually shout out to
Discord for sponsoring this portion of
today's video so with the launch of
their new server subscription feature we
opened up an exclusive premium area on
our Discord server where members can ask
the team including me you know general
questions about tech or any of the
content and getting exclusive Insider
info that you won't find anywhere else
like this test and also if you're
wondering Discord does it right with
Revenue split it's 90 10. so 90 going to
the Creator so your subscription
directly supports us and if you're a
Creator looking for more information on
this particular feature and adding it to
your own Discord definitely check out
the link below so anyway I dropped the
site in there a bunch of you got in
there quick and voted and basically we
got the data back in this text format it
looks kind of messy at first but
actually it's super helpful and we can
work with this a summary of how many
times every single matchup got voted on
and the votes for each side and also
since I had a lot of help with building
this site and loading up all the
pictures even though I know which phones
were involved I don't know which phones
took which pictures so I could blind
test myself and it was every bit as
engaging as I was hoping I could kind of
tell some of the phones that I think
took certain pictures but for the most
part I would just take a glance and if I
was seeing those two pictures side by
side on like Instagram or Twitter I'm
just picking the better one no pixel
peeping or thorough inspection it's just
picture on the internet vote and in the
end my standard Picture Winner was G my
low light winner was K and my portrait
mode winner was also K so everything
looked like it was working the data
processing was working as we wanted so
the only thing left to do
was send it live and here we go so as
soon as it went public you guys jumped
right on it it peaked at around 35
000 votes per minute and then ended up
totaling more than 21 million votes in
about three days there were essentially
zero Bad actors and now we have a load
of data many of you may have gone
through this which means you've done the
voting and now you have your letter
which means it's time to reveal all the
smartphones that were involved in this
test
and here you go a through P that's all
16 phones right there in their orders
which means the winner when I blind took
the test myself for my standard photo
was the pixel 6A
my winner for portrait mode and night
mode was the pixel 7. but what were the
overall winners according to Statistics
over the 20 plus million votes according
to science
I don't know if there's any other
collection of data like this anywhere on
the internet so this is super cool to
get into so let's dig into it so first
of all overall winner so with the
highest average ELO rating across all
three categories in third place is the
Asus Zenfone 9 in second place is the
pixel 7 Pro and first place is the pixel
6A The People's Choice camera of 2022
but there is a lot of fascinating
information to unpack here so first of
all doing well in one category did not
necessarily guarantee doing well across
any of the other categories right so the
pixel 7 Pro came in second fourth and
first in the three categories the pixel
6A came in third second and second but
the Oppo Find X5 Pro actually came in
first for standard then third for low
light and 15th for portrait mode this
basically means that if you wanted you
could argue for the the importance of
this standard photo over the low light
or the portrait mode photos so let's say
the standard photo is like three times
as important to most people as the other
two categories which feels about right
with that weighted importance on
standard photos then the Oppo Find X5
Pro becomes the overall winner which is
interesting and in case you're wondering
where the iPhone was and all this the
iPhone 14 pro tested in sixth place
tenth place and fifth place but in
Natural Curiosity for me anyway was to
ask what were the biggest losers which
ones got absolutely destroyed the most
in this test
and your Undisputed winners of losing
the most is the Sony Xperia 1 mark IV
and the Moto Edge 30 Ultra these phones
performed terribly in these tests so the
Sony despite its world-class sensor and
extremely Advanced apps when in full
auto like the rest of these phones did
not produce good pictures and ended up
with the lowest average ELO rating
across all three categories and then the
Moto Edge 30 Ultra actually had the most
overall losses it took a bizarre
sequence of photos including an
extremely dark standard light photo and
an incredibly over sharpened low-light
photo that it's the only one to have two
million total votes against it now
here's another interesting thought
votes per dollar if we wanted to sort by
bang for the buck basically which ones
if we account for the launch price the
MSRP which one was performing the best
relative to its price and the two
winners for votes per dollar by far are
the pixel 6A no surprise over 4 200
votes per dollar and the realme 10 Pro
Plus also sneaks in there the only other
phone up over four thousand votes per
dollar sneaky good camera phone for 379.
and then the obvious losers again are
the 900 Moto Edge and the one thousand
six hundred dollar Sony Xperia one four
also I just had to I had to look through
the text files and find the biggest dunk
just the biggest overall match-up
discrepancy between two phones in any
category and I found it that would be
portrait mode pixel 7 Pro versus Sony
Xperia 1 mark IV with the pixel winning
98 of the votes here so to the 1523
review that voted for the Sony here not
sure what you saw that the rest of us
didn't but overall just more than seeing
which ones got the most votes is seeing
why certain phones and certain pictures
got the most votes and the best way to
do that was actually just putting all of
the photos in order side by side in
order of how many votes they got and
that's how we started to see some really
interesting patterns so like for example
last time in the head to head we kind of
established that in a case of a versus B
if one photo's a little brighter than
the other it'll probably win
but how far can that go is there a such
thing as too bright in this case and it
turned out yes this is all the standard
Mode photos in order and yes the three
darkest photos are the three biggest
losers hands down they crushed any
Shadow detail in my hair and the
extremely comfortable sweater I'm
wearing on shop.comphd.com but right
above that is three of the absolute
brightest photos like these were just
Overexposed straight up matter of fact
it looks like we kind of got this order
of great photos then too bright then too
dark so it shows me that good exposure
wins but if you're gonna miss then yeah
people would rather have it be too
bright than too dark with night mode
altogether and in order you can kind of
see a bit of the same thing so the most
neutral correct exposures generally one
if they were sharp this time there's
about four good exposures Vivo x80 Pro
pixel 6A Oppo Find X5 Pro and pixel 7
Pro then there's the two brights which
people mostly preferred over the two
darks also there were some seriously
wild things happening with some of these
photos in low light the Vivo I mean it
absolutely nailed it it's clearly the
low light King the s22 ultra
interestingly came in fifth place even
when completely missing focus on my
stationary face and hitting the
background for some reason uh the iPhone
14 pro did an enormous amount of HDR
that had me looking kind of green like a
zombie but it still came in 11th place
here
the Moto Edge Plus as I mentioned kicked
out maybe the most over sharpened photo
the world has ever seen and then in dead
last is the iPhone SE the only phone in
this test that does not have night mode
and the sad thing is like it does have
ois it does have a decent sensor and it
does have a new processor but Apple just
feels the need to protect their more
expensive phones with more premium
features so they didn't give the SC
night mode and it suffered big time here
then in portrait mode we have the most
variety of them all because not only are
we judging things that we normally would
about a photo like sharpness color
exposure Etc but we are also now adding
cut out quality and artificially blurred
background quality and every phone uses
a slightly different focal length for
their portrait mode by default some of
them do a 2X portrait mode some of them
2.5 some of them 3x some of them even do
1X but combining all of these factors
the pixel 7 Pro absolutely dominated
portrait mode this was The Runaway
winner here in this category great
cutout great exposure great colors and a
nice soft background it nailed it but
guess what the pixel 6A was in second
and the real me 10 Pro Plus snuck in
there in third right above what I
consider the best cutout of the entire
competition which came from this Galaxy
s22 Ultra I think it's pretty close to
perfect at Edge detection here pretty
Sim similar to the Zenfone 9's cutout
but a better overall photo so it got
fourth place instead of seventh I was
also curious if there would be a
correlation between how many votes a
phone got and whether or not they used
more of a telephoto focal length just
because it maybe would feel more natural
having a blurred background if you're at
3x but when we lined it all up there was
almost no trend line at all and no
correlation so that was interesting
really the only other definite thing I
noticed about portrait mode photos is
that the three worst photos that got the
fewest votes by far were also by far the
brightest photos so see it turns out you
can overdo the brightness and that I
think that is basically it
so summary time just from all the data
that we have things that we learned
number one is that being really good in
one of these categories did not
necessarily guarantee being good at the
others that's clearly reflected in the
data
two is that pixel 6A and the real me 10
Pro Plus turned out to be the best bang
for the buck as far as a smartphone
camera from the phones that came out in
2022 and the pixel 6A being the overall
winner actually matches with it winning
our bracket style social media polling
blind test from last year which the
pixel 5A won and last but not least yeah
brighter photos do typically win but you
can in fact be too bright so I think
this mission was a success we learned a
lot I will say congrats to the pixel 6A
on the People's Choice Awards so to
speak and you know what we're going to
leave up the voting website till let's
say through the end of this year till
the end of January how about so January
31st is the last day you'll be able to
go to vote.mkbhd.com and blind test
yourself and I think we'll replace the
letters now with the actual names of the
phones now that it's been revealed but
we don't want to have to pay for all
this terabytes of data processing
forever so that's deadline so thanks to
y'all on the Discord for helping us beta
test this thing thanks to Zach for
helping us build this site and implement
the ELO style power ranking system
and thanks to you
for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace